we just spent half hour talking about
this and I hardly ever talk about it why
it's not wrong I didn't say it was wrong
okay
world renowned astrophysicist turned TV
host he's a man with the answers to the
toughest questions on the planet and of
course best-selling author in the last
50 years we've increased life expectancy
20 years there will be a time where Homo
sapiens have achieved escape velocity
from Death that generation will never
die unless you're hit by a bus that
brings to you the question if you could
live forever would you
how different the world would be what
are the things that you are most
concerned about with the direction of
travel of the human race a lot of things
so there's some delusional Force
operating on people's understanding of
the world in which they live if you post
an opinion on anything it gets attacked
do you see what happened with Neil
deGrasse Tyson she tweeted something
that many people took great offense to
part of what it is to be a scientist is
figure out all the ways you could bias
yourself and remove them as far as
possible don't let it interfere with
objective truths but what's the personal
toll on you I don't know why he tweeted
that stupid and awful he's just a weird
Twitter lunatic
is it
how long can I keep talking about
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
I have always believed that to fully
understand a person you have to
understand their origin story maybe
that's a similar sort of
analogy for the universe so the place I
wanted to start with you is by
understanding the most important context
from your earliest years that are
responsible for the person that is sat
in front of me today
wow this is a very Marvel Comics of you
like what's the origin story of Superman
Batman Spider-Man uh your question is
very well placed because
everyone who's been touched by some
series of events unfortunately some for
some people traumatic events but for all
people some series of events that shaped
who they are and I'd like to say that
there was a series of events that
planted the seeds of who I would become
but I I wouldn't say that they were
responsible I mean it requires a lot of
continual investment of time energy
and focus
to shape a career
rather than say oh it happened then and
I'd just been coasting ever since no
that's not how that works so
I grew up in the Bronx
and in New York City surely as is true
in London you don't have a relationship
with the night sky
in a busy City you at least certainly in
New York City there were tall buildings
if you look up to see the sky there's a
building in the way there's light
pollution there's and back then there
was air pollution
so
since no one has a relationship with
with the night sky then one can ask what
is your access to it of course it's our
local planetarium the Hayden Planetarium
and
I my family my parents my brother and
sister
there was a tactical strategic thing my
parents did I didn't know it at the time
but every weekend or every other weekend
we went places we were exposed to all
manner of things
that talented adults do
Beyond just the doctor lawyer you know
engineer Beyond those standard
professions so first it was entertaining
but it also meant
we had exposure
to other ways of thinking about what you
might do with your life
one of those trips when I was nine years
old was to the Hayden Planetarium
and I was Star Struck
you sit in a big chair and the lights
dim and the stars come out more stars
than you can count
and I thought it was a hoax I said there
aren't that many stars I've seen the
night sky from the Bronx you're lying to
me and only later what I learn upon
going deep into the rural areas of the
country we have relatives in the
Caribbean we visited there I'd see the
night sky
as nature intended
it's day
when I have access to Great telescopes
on mountaintops and I look up at this
crystalline clear night skies
I still say to myself oh that is so
beautiful it reminds me of the Hayden
planetarium
so it's a
uh I know that's kind of a sad
commentary on what it is to grow up in a
city but it's
I feel like the universe chose me and
since I was nine years old onward I have
committed my life to learning more and
more about the universe and that that's
the the most important seed that was
planted
cyrillan Sun cheetah is that your
parents Cheryl is my father and son
cheetah is my mother correct what was
the influence that they individually had
on you from the from almost vicariously
learning from them but also the direct
influence they had on you
they were immoral influence a cultural
influence
and I will add
not that you explicitly ask this but I
think it fits right in this moment
um
consider the period the 1960s
you could go one of two ways if you're
an angry black man
it's like you can raise your fist
and threaten violence
as a retaliation of the violence against
you
or you can find some other way that
doesn't involve violence that involves
some kind of Peace some kind of
understanding
and my father and while he grew up in
the 30s and 40s he served in a
segregated Army okay so the stuff he
lived through
and while I have my own stories none of
them compare to his average story yet at
the end of the day he was never bitter I
remembered him saying when you look at
the images of angry
white people
screaming at black children entering a
school who are protected by the National
Guard because an edict had to be
delivered to grant them access to
education
he would say
they simply don't know any better
they were raised that way
you want
to hate them
and
my father never hated
never
so I go through life and at least
several times a week every week of my
life growing up I have stories today
they would call them microaggressions
but then it was just
same [ __ ] different day
but I never got bitter because you asked
what influence do they have on me it was
the non-bitter
influence you say
that's they don't know any better they
think they're doing the right thing
maybe we can make a difference
going forward
I saw the emotion in your face when you
talked about your father yeah it's
I think we need that today
the world
I I reached a point where okay
how long can I keep talking about
the universe
and not bring it down to earth
not bring some science principles to
people's thinkings
they want to tribalize they want to hate
they want to choose
you want to create laws
to restrict your freedoms just because
of
who you worship or don't worship or who
you sleep with or what you look like or
what you know how reflective
to light your skin color is right what
side of a Line in the Sand
you
were born on
I like invoking an alien trope
aliens they don't know anything about us
they just see this beautiful planet with
water on it and
continents and clouds and they visit and
they say this is cool oh this is one
species that's everywhere oh they're
very successful they're humans and
they're Homo sapiens and heck that's
cool and then they get a little closer
look and they say oh my gosh what are
they there's a war over here why oh
because there's some resource on this
side that's not over there and they want
it there's a coastline there's oil
there's this there's a elements in a
mine they they they they worship a
different God
to look at the violence and hatred that
we commit upon each other
and they'll run back home and tell their
fellow alien brethren
there's no sign of intelligent life on
Earth
so
anyhow so I've I've yeah my head has
been in the stars but my feet have been
on Earth my entire life
why why does that
connect so deep because it's so obvious
it connects so deeply with you is that
linked to what the resilience to
bitterness that your father demonstrated
when he was abused and was
attacked with racial abuse is that is
that the reason why it's so linked so
closely to your heart I I don't know
um
he didn't he didn't burden us with his
stories unless we asked or unless it
came up in a moment it was it wasn't
that way
it was I saw his Integrity in the face
of what was going on in the world and
it's
you can
a person could be a mentor even if they
don't say anything
because you can observe them
observe their conduct
their their behavior their how they
respond to adversity
do they fight back
do they want to commit violence
do they
want to have a conversation
to explore the differences
you know I am I'm uh my mother's from
Nigeria my dad's from England so I'm of
I guess dual ethnicity or whatever the
politically correct term is it's called
human okay I'm human just say it repeat
after me what race are you you're the
human race you you just spent 10 seconds
telling me how anthropologists liked to
divide up the world and force us to then
agree with their categories
line everybody up from Ghost white to
coal black and you'll have a human being
of every single skin color in between
okay well did you happen to be born over
there so you're human
tell me which mixture you are I don't
give a rat's ass okay you're a human
being sitting across the table from me
now continue sorry sorry it's your
podcast I don't mean to jump all in
myself it's fine I'm fine with it
and I've I've come to learn about what
it was to be
black in the
1960s 70s from my guest and it's helped
me to understand my mother better
because I have to I have my mother
didn't react like your father did
you talked about my mother was like
Nigerian she came to the UK we lived in
an all-white area she didn't react like
your father did and so it skewed my
perspective on on race relations but
then from doing this podcast and meeting
people like you hearing some of those
very specific stories of abuse I almost
can't believe it and now I have this
huge amount of empathy for my mother
because I've sat here with the guests
and one of the stories I heard you tell
was about your
farther competing in athletics and how
people would scream the n-word at him
while he was running oh yeah so that
this was for me one of the most
insightful
lessons
that I got from all the stories from him
yes so he uh he was a an athlete
actually world-class track
uh that's its own story because he he
was uh kind of muscular all right
certainly in his day not Charles Atlas
muscular but relative to other kids in
his class in high school he was muscular
and they were in their gym class and you
line up and getting ready for the next
unit right there was gymnastics and then
there was like track and field so they
had the track unit and that gym teacher
pointed to my father
on the line and said we're about to do
the running unit and just so you know
um
do you see Cyril Tyson over there the
returns he said he has the kind of body
that would not make a good runner
and he said to himself
no one is going to tell me what I can't
do in this world
and he started running
and he became world class and at one
point he had the fifth fastest time in
the world
in his special event so that was that's
an important lesson career lesson
why are there people running around
telling you what you can't accomplish in
a free Society
I can get it if we're not a free Society
but why should anyone tell you what you
can't or shouldn't do
so that was lesson number one for me
but then
his best friend also a runner
Johnny Johnson was his name
uh
there's a race Johnny Johnson is running
around on the last turn of the track
and there's a runner from the New York
Athletic Club several Paces behind him
the coach of that Runner
goes up the side of the track
and screams to his Runner
as he points to Johnny Johnson ahead of
him
catch that
Johnny Johnson overheard this foreign
Johnson said to himself was
this is one he ain't gonna catch that's
just and increase the distance okay so
so that comment from the coach
could have done one of two things it
could have demotivated you because then
you wallow in the racism of the world
or it could motivate you to succeed
ever since I heard that story
every racist encounter I have ever had
simply motivates me to succeed all the
more
period
and I see that throughout your story as
you go through you know College
University
um and you go into your post grad
there's moments over and over again
where people or circumstance encourage
you away from what's clearly your
passion the thing you're clearly
pursuing yeah people didn't yeah and
again this is not the kind of racism
that the 1950s or 40s you know I wasn't
lynched yeah you know so so again I
don't want to claim
equal I'm trauma to what earlier
Generations had experienced but you can
get let's call it institutional racism
where you don't even racism I'm talking
about people trying to put you off your
passion telling you that's I call you
that racist what I'm saying is they see
that I'm athletic I'm athletic most of
my life
and they can't wrap their head around me
being something other than an athlete
that they watch on television
when I say well I actually like
astrophysics but you're so good at this
other sport
no I want to be in the physics Club no
we we need you on the the basketball
team
and they think they're doing me a favor
they think they're saying nice things to
me
but every one of those is a force
operating against my ambitions
and so in a way just that my skin color
in my life's Arc was a path of most
resistance compared to where I wanted to
land
and by the way I don't we are we just
spent a half hour talking about this and
I hardly ever talk about it I don't talk
about because I don't you know
I don't need to maybe if it's a
counseling session but I'm perfectly
fine
I'm a happy guy happily married got two
kids and
I hardly ever talk about skin color
because
I I want to make it irrelevant as
quickly as I possibly can
in every context
I'm possibly in
so if you're going to invite me to give
a public talk in February Black History
Month I will decline that invitation
if you only think of me as a black
scientist
then I have failed as a scientist
period
period
uh you want me to oh what do
you know how I realized this okay so I
will tell you the moment after which
I was a different person interacting
with the public
okay I'm in graduate school there's an
explosion on the Sun
and the Press it's over the wires press
hears about this so they want to get a
comment on it
explosion on the Sun so they called
Columbia the department of astronomy and
they're looking for some it was lunch
time
they were all out to lunch
I'm a I'm a grant I'm a doctoral
candidate I'm there for my PhD and so
the department uh admin is going through
the the roster and they get to me say
Neil no one is here can you take this
call so I said sure and they said oh
hello who are you I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson doctoral candidate and
astrophysics they say you know there's
an explosion on the sun should we be
worried I said oh it's a solar flare
they happen with some frequency it's a
wave of particles coming towards Earth
and they said you mean the Earth is fine
I said the Earth is fine and they said
can you tell us that on camera
sure okay we'll send up a limo to pick
you up in a half hour
and so the whole conversation there was
and it was pre-taped I get home I put on
the TV
and I watched this interview
and I had an out of Body Experience
I just witnessed something I've never
seen before in my life
you know what that was
it was the news
interviewing a black person me
who is not an Entertainer or athlete
okay
interviewing a black person
for expertise that had nothing to do
with being black
the interview didn't say at the end well
how do black people feel about solar
flares oh does this affect affect dark
skin differently none of that
it was
will Earth be safe
and he's getting that expertise from a
black person I had never seen that and
then I thought well is it just because
I'm on TV and I'm a little more aware
so I watched for the next two years
every time there was a black person
brought onto the news for expertise
it was someone who's a member of
Congress representing a community and
they want Enterprise zones for the
economics there is someone who is
worried about the poverty and the inner
city
never
had an audience seen a black person as
an expert
oh they would have attorneys but it's
talking about a court case about a black
person
would they ever being a black attorney
to talk about a court case about a white
person no
and I said to myself that's
is the answer
that's how I we turn an entire world of
people who think black people are just
dumb and stupid lazy shiftless and all
they can do is shine my shoes and
entertain me and sing and be the athlete
on the field if there was an ever a
force to change that
it's not people telling them they should
think differently
it's me being visible in a way
where they have no other choice but to
say oh my gosh this person knows more
about this subject than I do and he has
dark skin
so the next time they see a homeless
black person they're not saying oh black
people are just like they have to
confront the fact that they just saw a
black person tell them that Earth was
safe
so it's just quite simple the next time
you're driving your car and somebody
comes up with a squeegee to wash your
window at the red light and begs for
money and if that person is black
maybe you'll think twice
about the causes and effects of poverty
of the forces that operate that
discriminate against one community of
people versus another
so ever since that moment I have
declined interviews
that want me
because I'm black
and even in this interview I'm not
entirely comfortable spending a half
hour talking about it because it
it turns this interview into something
about me being black
which then is someone hears or hears me
for the first time oh let's get him he
has all these stories about being black
let's get him to talk to this group
about in this racial uh in this race
conference no
I will decline that invitation
so let's talk about
[Music]
um
a separate Point what advice would you
give me on how you pursue the thing that
sets your heart on fire your passion or
whatever you want to call it without
falling into the OR conforming to the
like external pressure to become a
doctoral lawyer like I'm thinking about
the people that are watching this that
have a passion but they don't consider
it to be a job as many people didn't
consider what you do now to be a job
back then and they're being forced by
the external words parents expectations
social media to go and do something else
they don't want to do what would you say
to those people
I can tell you this that if you don't
have I didn't realize when I was nine
how unusual it was to be that passionate
that young not until I got to college
half the people my freshman year didn't
yet know what they wanted to major in
and I said I'm majoring in astrophysics
I say it was that because it was early
in the catalog alphabetically of things
you might major no I felt this and known
this half my life
and so I I in college I was sensitized
to people who were still looking
still searching
well we have the benefit of longer life
expectancy today than 50 years ago
I mentioned this only because if you
don't want to be if you don't know what
you want to be when you grow up
and you're 30 that's just fine
but
I don't want to have to blame you for
not exposing yourself to what you can be
when you grow up
if you're sitting home watching football
and say I don't know what I want to do
with my life
once you do what my parents did
visit a new thing every weekend go on a
trip
talk to experts in all manner of tasks
and you know visit a chef School visit a
a geology
Expedition do just do things and if you
like it
you'll probably be better at that than
anything else you choose to do
because you you will invest even your
downtime doing it
and as the saying goes
pick something you would do for free
and make that your career
and you'll never live a sad day in your
life
so that's one variant on a pick
something that you love
and all the time when other people say
you know I need a vacation from this job
you you're going to say vacation what's
that
people say that to me do you want a
vacation from from what
from the astrophysics you're doing but I
like what I'm doing
if I'm on vacation I love being on the
beach but from the beach I'm thinking
about
it first it's not to get away from the
universe all right not that that could
literally happen anyway so
that's what I would say you want to be
independent minded listen to people's
comments people have life experience
don't ignore it but what you want to do
is fold it in to your own sensibilities
provided you have sensibilities to begin
with otherwise you become this ping pong
ball a batted back and forth between one
person suggestion and another
in the cover of your book
um it talks about the polarization that
we're we're seeing in the world at the
moment what is you know what is the what
are the things that you are most
concerned about when you think about the
direction of travel of the human race
and life here on Earth and what's going
on what are the things that trouble you
at a very deep level in terms of our
direction of travel a lot of things
so
let me put this in context
in science if I put a conclusion forward
it's not you're not going to ask me did
you look at both sides of that
no that's not the question is did you
look at all sides of it
we have this binary mind where we think
oh you're forming are you force or
against us is it black or white are you
a boy are you a girl is it up or is it
down this is intellectually lazy because
practically everything that exists in
this universe manifests on a spectrum
so here's a Here's a thought and you're
gonna say well did you look at both no I
looked at all sides did you realize that
if this changes that could change this
and did you did you figure out how
sensitive it is to that if I didn't I'm
not doing my job as a scientist okay
so we live in a Time
especially fractured by the forces of
social media I say this only because if
you post an opinion on anything
in social media
it gets attacked you'll be people who
agree with it fine but the noise and the
fireworks
are when you get attacked
I don't think it used to be that way
I think there was a time when
I would Express an opinion and you say
oh that's interesting here's my opinion
uh so why do you think that way and
here's why I think that that's
interesting I never thought about it
that way cool you spend 15 minutes talk
comparing and con contrasting opinions
then you go out for a beer at the pub
this is how I remembered it am I
misremembering I I don't think so
it could be attacked now what are the
consequences what do you actually after
by attacking someone with a different
opinion oh I know what it is you want
everyone to have exactly the same
opinion you do
well that's not this country either
no
you know what's on our currency
on our currency e pluribus unum okay
out of the many we have won
not out of the one we have one
it is the many it is the plurality
pluribus it's Latin okay
a plurality means people coexist who
think differently about the world and we
celebrate that or at least we ought to
otherwise we're all the same and we can
make a country where everybody's the
same and that's called a dictatorship is
that really what it really
think through fully the consequences of
that let me get back to the violence
part I want to do on the point of social
media you had a you had a tweet that you
did that went viral that got attacked
right I mean there was one in particular
that I think
was was attacked him on the others I
can't even remember it off the top it's
never my intent yeah to post a tweet
that gets attacked of course if it gets
attacked it's like I didn't see that
coming I I count myself as an educator
among the ranks of Educators and
my goal is to Enlighten and educate not
to anger people so I still maintain a
forbidden Twitter file on my computer
these are tweets
that no I'm not going to post it even
though it's true objectively true it
would be too upsetting to people is
there another way so anytime that
happens like oh my gosh okay let me see
if I can tune that differently next time
but if you know it's true and you
believe it's important
you still might not post it because it
might upset people
in ways that are not productive give me
an example no no I will quote my father
okay
it's not good enough to be right
you also have to be effective
if you're not effective go home
doesn't matter if you are in the right
so if I post something that just creates
more
divisiveness
I need to find another way to achieve
the same goal without the conflict so no
I'm not just about put the truth out
there and if it if if it triggers
landmines so what it's the truth no
that's not being an educator I'm really
there's a point here I really want to
answer for my for my own because
something I've been thinking a lot about
as we see this polarization in every
facet of conversation and public
discourse I've started to think that
maybe the antidote is the very few
amongst us that have the guts to stand
by the truth regardless of the hours
they take and I'm seeing that a little
bit with with some big commentators I
shout name names because that'll be a
headline but um I'm thinking actually
they're like their they're braver I
guess in the courage to say the truth
regardless of the fact they're going to
get piled on because it doesn't fit the
narrative is actually helping us
it's helping us almost
um
yeah it's it's helping it moves the
needle yeah yeah okay so I I see that
I'm just saying
I believe however delusionally that you
can achieve the same goal without
angering people
and part of the goal of that book is to
offer ways to think about points of
conflict
in fresh ways that do not
trigger people to dig their heels in and
fight more ferociously to defend their
opinions
now I want to put this in context
because I started out by describing an
idea and you're gonna say did you
consider both sides no I consider it all
sides
I'm
people want to think we're in the most
violent times can we look at violence
against trans the trans community
first there was always violence against
trans people nobody was talking about it
because there's violence against
other people there were violence against
black people there's violence against
women there's there's a whole list of
people
who were more represented
statistically in the world than trans
people
where we went through periods of our
social justice Arc
to try to rectify those problems
and so
the fact that trans rights are on the
table now
is itself a measure of progress
because we're not talking about
gay marriage anymore
we're not talking under President
Clinton one of our more more Progressive
liberal presidents do you know what the
the thing was it was
gays in the military don't ask don't
tell
that was considered a progressive stance
in the 1990s under a liberal president
don't ask don't tell
now in Qatar
with the with the they say we will
welcome uh gay people but don't exhibit
the gayness in the stands
and everyone is jumping all over them
for that regressive posture
it's exactly what we were 30 years ago
don't ask don't tell
I don't mind if your gay just don't kiss
another man in front of me if you're a
man
otherwise okay with it all right
so what I'm saying is
look at the other things that preceded
it and you can declare progress having
led up to it that's my point not that
it's still you don't still have to worry
about it and it still needs Solutions
and you still have to
somehow change people's sense of what
equality is and equal access and
opportunity and equity and inclusion
that all still needs to happen
but
that is not happening now
or less so with black people so there
are measures of progress that are kind
of perverse
but real
you know what my father used to say he
said I'll know we've achieved equality
when a black person can be indicted
for embezzlements
when a black person can be sent to jail
for embezzling
500 million dollars I know we've made it
okay okay like it's a perverse measure
but it's it's another way to think about
the progress that has actually happened
in this world
all I'm saying is
we may be living in some of the safest
times there ever was in the history of
civilization
I don't think we should lose sight of
that people are afraid to say it I think
because the worry and it's an authentic
a legitimate worry that you might just
get complacent and sit back and say see
everything is fine it requires no more
work and no more effort
I'm saying
Maybe
we should pick
in addition to worrying about the
violence that persists to this day
we should look at the successes
and say well what did we do right
let's do more of that
and there's not much of people saying
look how far we've come
let's list how we achieve this why don't
people do that well on Twitter two days
ago and the question was do you it was
essentially do you feel optimistic about
the future I clicked yes and I was in
the tiny minority in 78 roughly 70
percent of people I think was slightly
more felt pessimistic about the future
either worried and fearful about the
future right and there's here's another
statistic which is in the spirit of that
but it's a little more more thorough it
was uh Gallup poll one of the I forgot
which one it might have been a different
one but one of the official polling
agencies uh for the past 30 years
have asked people
each year
in the United States
um
are things more dangerous for you
just in your community and in your this
year than last year
27 of those years
people said it's more dangerous this
year than last year I don't feel as safe
as I did last year
okay now let's plot the crime rate over
the past 30 years it has been a
precipitous drop
this is Trump
there's some bumps in there but
basically it has dropped for 30 years
since the basically the 1980s 90s up
until today
so there's some delusional Force
operating on people's understanding of
the world in which they live
and then people wanted to blame it I
think in part correctly on local news
what's the first thing you see you put
on not the national the local news
um there's a crime committed and that we
have video Services you know we didn't
used to have surveillance video now you
see the person beating up on the old
person or the person breaking into the
jewelry now you see it you say oh my
gosh
um you know clutch your blood your loved
ones and your valuables our ability to
show you violence is greater than ever
before
and it affects us emotionally
part of what it is to be a scientist is
to figure out all the ways you could
bias yourself
and remove them as far as possible as
much as you can
what is the scientific method if not
I give my own wording of the scientific
method it's simply
do whatever it takes
to not fool yourself
into thinking something is true that is
not
or that something is not true that is
so I so that poll would have told me I'm
going to look at the actual data
and I'm going to look at the and I'm
going to react to the actual data not to
my feelings about an objective truth
nothing wrong with feelings it's the
source of the greatest art in the world
and it's our emotions how we feel for
people but if you're going to make
legislation
if you're going to act on your feelings
and there's an objective truth that
informs those of feelings
that's the path you should take
otherwise we're a house of cards that
could collapse at any moment because
somebody feels like you're gonna harm
them or they feel like it's dangerous or
they feel like
excuse me
I love human feelings but don't let it
interfere with objective truths don't
let it interfere with legislation laws
that would have to affect us all
the quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life huel has been probably the
most important important partner in my
health Journey because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and that's why it's such a
wonderful thing to be able to talk to
this audience about brand and a product
that is so unbelievably linked to my
values and the place I am in my life of
valuing the gym exercise movement my
mind my breathing and all of those
things and most importantly my nutrition
that is the role he all plays and so
every time I get to read these ads I do
it with such passion because I really
really believe every word I'm saying and
I absolutely love the brand so if you
haven't already tried Hill and you've
been resistant to my my pestering then
give it a go and let me know how you get
on we're lucky enough to have Intel
sponsoring this podcast and Intel Evo is
essentially their Badge of Excellence
that determines whether a laptop is high
spec or not so it's going to save you a
load of time researching and comparing
models because if you see the Intel Evo
badge you know it's past Intel's own
strict requirements for laptops that
prioritize on-the-go productivity one of
those requirements for Intel Evo is the
real world battery life and fast
charging when you're in a rush intellivo
laptops have long lasting fast charging
batteries which takes a lot of boxes for
me you'll get at least four hours worth
of charge in under 30 minutes of being
plugged in and a battery life designed
to last at least nine or more hours even
if you're like me and have multiple tabs
open the laptop was also really
responsive with the Intel Evo platform
it wakes up in less than a second and
comes with 12th generation Intel core
processors built into the laptop so it's
ready to go instantly as someone who
spent a lot of my time out and about
between podcast recordings talks
meetings business meetings events
etc etc being able to rely on a laptop
to keep going at the pace I do is
critical and with the Intel Evo platform
you get the performance and the battery
life you need to do just that head to
intel.co.uk EVO to find out more about
the Intel Evo platform your documentary
Cosmos I don't know if I'm saying that
right Cosmos Cosmos I think it's a it
might be in English you're a Brit I
don't know how you pronounce anything
Cosmos okay you will never find an
American correcting British
pronunciation since we just don't know
yeah okay um so objective truth and
reality and feelings one of the things I
learned from that documentary which was
I honestly I I remember the day I found
it
I shouldn't say this but I didn't have a
lot of money so I found it on some like
dodgy like pirated website and I just I
watched I think it was eight episodes
security yeah I watched them all that
night and I and then I went back and
watched the previous one with Carl Sagan
um it just captivated me and it has ever
since I actually would cite that as my
as the start of my fascination with the
universe and one of the really profound
things I took from it when we're talking
about objective truth and feelings is
there's a scene in in the documentary
where you kind of like zoom out and it
keeps going and going and going and
going and going and going and it made me
talking about objective truth and
feelings it made me feel so
insignificant I realized that I am
objectively irrelevant and that was a
wonderful feeling because with that it
strips away the the burden of your own
self-importance and ego
um do we matter
so the cosmic perspective is
incompatible with your ego okay
I should say your ego is incompatible
with the cosmic perspective that's the
proper way to order that sentence the
constant perspective shows you how small
we are
in size in time
in space
and if you go in with a high ego you
might resist that you might say no I'm
important I
but I think of it differently
the
we know one of the greatest Gifts of
modern astrophysics to civilization
dare I call it a gift
is the knowledge that the atoms of your
body
are traceable
not only to the Big Bang origin of the
universe itself
but especially to Stars
that it manufactured those elements
and later in their lives on death
exploded scattering that enrichment
across gas clouds
so that their next generation of stars
would have planets and on at least one
of those planets life
so
we are not
just figuratively we are literally
Stardust
so when you go out and look up at the
night sky
yeah your urge is I'm small and that's
large
and yes you're alive in this universe
but there's another way to look at it
the universe is alive within you
you have kinship
with the cosmos
that
feeling to me is greater than any ego
you could have possibly walked into the
room with
first that feeling borders on spiritual
second third
we have trained ourselves
to equate
being special with being different
you're special
you do something thinks some way that no
one else does
so I'm special
well let me turn that on its head
and say
maybe we're special
not because we're different
but because we're the same
all humans
are Stardust
all humans share a chemistry
with all a biology with all other life
on Earth
there's one Genesis on this Earth
we have DNA and you have DNA in common
with a banana
I beg your pardon
you can ask well where are the arms and
legs no DNA goes deeper than that
DNA controls chemistry it controls
metabolism it controls all kinds of
things that are prescribed in the DNA
and that's where we have commonality
with other life forms on Earth
so why not look around and say
I'm not special because I'm a different
I'm special because I'm the same as you
as others
as the tree as the brook as the animals
you know the Woodland creatures and we
can all sit here and look up at the
night sky and say yes we have kinship
with the cosmos
I feel large because of that not small
you mentioned the pursuit of happiness
Ali when you're talking about one of the
central sort of like Doctrine doctrines
of the American dream that pursuit of of
happiness and um
you know in what you've just said about
the Universe I was I was pondering where
meaning is derived from so I'll kind of
asked the question at the same time this
happiness and meaning where does where
does that come from in in your
perspective
what I have found is
is an urge people have
to search for meaning
is it under this rock behind
metaphorically right is it under a rock
I'm going to search is there meaning
that is it behind a tree
is if if I join this group well that
will be will I find meaning with them if
I and I think okay
go ahead
but what you do is relegating meaning in
your life to a search
and suppose you don't find meaning
that'd be a force of disappointment in
your life you're setting yourself up
to be disappointed
if you don't find meaning
so how I have another idea
I use this for myself I may or may not
work for others
I recognize long ago
that in a free Society
where I'm not enslaved and I'm not you
know an indentured servant and I have
some freedom of choice
that I have the power to manufacture
meaning in my life
I can make decisions about my own life
that create the meaning
for me
a meaningful life is learning something
new tomorrow that I didn't know
yesterday
otherwise it's a wasted day
you know the prisoner who puts x's in
the boxes on the wall for the day they
get out
I have that in my head and the day that
I got is the day I die all right and
what these boxes remind you of is every
day you're alive you're one day closer
to death
so there's one fewer days in there
to accomplish something that you might
have wanted to accomplish
so
I want to keep learning about our world
about each other about things I don't
otherwise know about
and
there are people who only read things
that they agree with or that they
already know about or that it's their
their feeding
some urge to be
on what's the word to be validated
I have books on my shelf
at my bedside
every book is a subject that I either
know nothing about or I completely
disagree with
going into the book
I said maybe it'll change my mind
learn new ideas
okay I once presented that list to the
New York Times when they said because I
my book was doing well at one point and
they try to get
authors to talk about other books to
keep the book Wheel turning because
fewer people are reading today so what
books are you reading so on your shelves
I've listed the books
one of them was
uh a book in his in his
30th printing or something it was
originally written back in the early 60s
I think maybe even the 50s a book by
Barry Goldwater it's called the
conscience of a conservative
and so I'm reading this and people wrote
to me after they saw this list they said
I didn't know you're a closet
conservative I didn't know you're really
a republican did you vote for Trump and
all of a sudden people were presuming
that if I'm reading a book on something
that book must be what my whole life is
about rather than it's a portal to
another place of how people think and
what people do
so that shocked me actually
that because that tells me that most
people must have just books that
continue to feed their own interests and
that is the best way to not grow in this
world so one of my measures of meaning
is how much more do I know about the
world tomorrow than I did yesterday
because
almost any path you take take will make
you wiser as a person
so I value wisdom that gives meaning to
my life A New Perspective it's not just
knowledge
no
what is the ark it's it's there's
there's data
data can become information
on further study becomes knowledge
and after enough time
when you see how the knowledge plugs in
and applies it can become wisdom
wisdom is the distilled essence of all
the details
the wisest statements ever spoken to you
generally have no detail in them at all
do they
it's as I've heard it said this way
wisdom is what's left over after you've
forgotten all the details it's the
distilled essence of it all so I want to
be wiser
on the porch on my rocking chair I don't
want to be the old curmudgeon
in my day we did it best no I don't want
to be that guy no
so that's one source
of meaning
another and it's just directly traceable
to my parents but I'd like to also think
it's traceable to
common sense
is
spend a little bit of your life
lessening the suffering of others
I don't mean redirect your life some
people do they work in soup kitchens and
start not-for-profits to serve yes
I I'm not that person
no because my the universe is what calls
me but in my day
in a week
do something
that lessens the suffering
of someone else
however trifling that gesture is
and
that's an infusion
of
good
yeah I'm value judging it I'm saying yes
it is a good thing to lessen the
suffering of others yeah I'm declaring
that I try not to ever put opinions out
there but it's my opinion that if you
lessen the suffering of others
you make a better world
and
don't we all want to live in a better
world
if your happiness were a recipe right
consisting of various ingredients that
needed to be present in certain
quantities for you to be a happy person
and under the assumption that you know
no one is perfectly happy under any kind
of vague sense of the word what what is
missing from your list of ingredients at
the moment
or what could you have more of that I
don't think of life that way okay how do
you think of Life how why is that wrong
that question I didn't say it was wrong
I don't value judge okay it's not what's
right or wrong it's it's
um
I don't live life that way
because
it means you carry with you the emotions
I could be happier if I were doing this
and how come I'm not and all of a sudden
well then I must be miserable if I'm not
as happy as I could be no I don't
measure day to day am I happy or not
I it's not the measure
yes it's in there
but that's not the metric the metric is
am I successful
at what at what I'm doing
am I no no
it's not even that it's am I as good at
this as I can be
if you're not going to try to improve go
home find something else
so
I remember in my first interview on
National Television
a new planet had just been discovered
around another star
an exoplanet it was Banner headlines we
now have 5 000 in the catalog but back
then in 1995 it was Banner headline
another planet
and we kind of always knew they'd be out
there we just didn't have the tools to
figure it out
NBC News sent an action cam up to the
Planetarium I was freshly appointed as
director they didn't know me as a person
but I carry title and so the Chiron on
the TV image gets to say Neil deGrasse
Tyson director Hayden planetarium okay
they came up and interviewed me tell us
about this new planet how was it
discovered right so I gave my best
professorial reply
best oh my gosh it was it's a Doppler
shift that the orbiting planet
um influences the position of the star
in space it's not just the star sits
there fixed in the universe and planets
orbit it they both orbit their common
center of gravity and so the star you
can't see the planet it's too dim but
you look at the star and the star is
jiggling back and forth and I motion
that with my body and I said and you
measure this movement back and forth
with the Doppler shift you calculate it
and you can infer the existence of this
planet and bada bing it's a planet
and I went on I went on for like
probably four times that length with my
Pro and then I go home it's national
news I get to call everybody hey
everybody my friends in California I'm
gonna be on TV check it out and so
when the segment aired
all they showed was me jiggling my hips
like this
and say it's a planet and I said oh
they don't want my professor reply they
want a reply that fits in their medium
a sound bite medium
so let me practice that
so I went home and stared in the mirror
and had people just shout out objects
names places people things and I
assembled sound bites for each one of
them it's like three sentences it's got
to be informative
makes you smile a little bit
and the information has to be tasty so
you want to tell someone else
that's a sound bite okay we could do
that now mention anything in the
universe just just not a question just a
word just anything Moz Mars ooh do you
know Mars is red because it's rust
it's a rusted planet
and rust has the color of red
the whole plant has a lot of iron on
Mars
and red is the color of blood
hence Mars the God of War
it might have life there we're still
looking
boom sound bite Venus okay
Venus the goddess of love and beauty
and Venus as an object in the night sky
is stupefyingly brilliant
until you learn it's has a runaway
greenhouse effect and it's 900 degrees
Fahrenheit 500 degrees Celsius on its
surface it would vaporize you
so much for the love and beauty and a
Venus so it's it's the least explored
Planet because of how hostile it is to
our
space probes
well we got this I'm not giving you a
10-minute lecture on the thermodynamics
of Venus so my point is
when I saw
that what I did did not serve the needs
I invested a lot of energy
so that I could be exactly what they
needed
so that their task is simplified and I
get better at something that could serve
a greater good
I'm not I don't want to say that's
happiness I'm going to say that's
fulfillment
of an objective where I improved in what
it is I was doing I have to say when I
know it's going to meet you this
question which was so friend of mine for
me is there is so many people that talk
about the stars in the universe but
there's only one you and what I mean by
that is I don't know what you mean by
that
so would I have had anyone else on this
podcast that talks about the stars in
the universe no the reason why you are a
dream guest is because you create a
bridge through exactly what you've
described making it engaging and
interesting and
uh
fun and exciting because of the way that
you communicate and like people don't
often think about this whether they're
computer programmers or they are
archaeologists or whatever that it's
great to know stuff but like I think
Ricky Gervais makes the joke where the
Daddy Long Legs where he says you can
have all the venom in the world but if
you don't have the the teeth to inject
the Venom if you don't have the skill of
like communication and storytelling and
engagement the Venom is pointless so
what I will say is
uh I will give one other example and
I'll tie a bow on it
uh the first time I was invited to
appear on The Daily Show it's a very
popular comedic news program in the
United States uh hosted by
um Jon Stewart
Justin was a comedian he's brilliant
he's very into current events we all
know him he's Sharp and I've seen
politicians get interviewed by him
and they want to deliver their stump
speech and their deer in the headlights
because he's just dancing circles around
them
and on my first interview I said I am
not going to be the deer in the
headlines okay so I studied his show
with a stopwatch and I said how many
seconds does he on average does he give
his guests to speak before he
comedically interrupts them
okay write that down
it was anywhere between 9 and 12 seconds
which doesn't sound like much but it's
it it works comedically right then I
said how far back in time does he
reference a current event
to put in a joke that he might give
because you can't go too far back
because no one remembers it the joke has
to work without you reminding people
what they're supposed to know so very
intensely the the previous day a little
less the second day by the time of the
third day in the past there's hardly any
reference to it okay
so
I studied the last two or three days of
current events
I practice my sound bites even more to
fit them into this time frame and I get
on the show
and I deliver the lines that means sound
bites oh but I come pre-loaded with
anything he could possibly ask me so I'm
like I'm I'm
I I waddle into the studio with a
utility belt's worth of thoughts and
ideas that he could be asking me okay
so I'm there and if you see me on these
shows I'm a little manic because the
it's coursing through me all this
knowledge and information that I need a
response to just in case he asks me so
we do this and I get the point and he
makes the comedic point and now my
thought is not dangling in the middle of
a joke because I completed the thought
the joke tightens that up and then we
move on right so we go through this
whole interview
Eddie mentions the current event and I
have a little sound bitey thing about
that after the interview people come up
to me you know what they said they said
Neil
you're such a natural and you have such
good chemistry with Jon Stewart my
they have no [ __ ] idea
how much time I invested
to look natural
pardon my expletive there but we smile
all the time yeah
what I'm saying is
I want it to be as good as I possibly
could have been in that interview
knowing his audience because each host
has their own audience you want to serve
Their audience I don't want to just give
the stump speech so everything that I
imagine for myself was for him and his
audience I would communicate differently
on a different talks daytime talk shows
are different than the evening comedic
news on a documentary it's different
so my only point of this with these
examples
are
I pay attention to whether people are
paying attention to me
if I'm giving you an explanation and
you're drifting that's not working let
me pull that out of the utility belt let
me try something else
um if I talk about black holes in a
particular oh you're leaning in in the
conversation in your eyebrows are right
that worked
so I have a database
of people's expressions
while I'm talking to them
and and I sift that yeah
yeah so that I pick and choose what is
most impactful in the few minutes we
have together otherwise I'm dragging you
through a syllabus that who the hell
cares
what are the devices that you you
probably don't do even do an
intentionally you're saying it's natural
you know don't edit that out okay but
okay so what are the what are the
devices that you intentionally work very
very hard on to employ that that I might
take from you and become as good a
speaker as you are as engaging and as
like captivating despite the fact that
you're delivering such complex subject
matter at times but it still seems
accessible to someone like me that is
just simply a a chimp not everything
that excites me as a professional in the
field
will excite you
you need to know
you need to sort them into those
categories
and maybe there's something that will
excite me and you'll see me get all
excited and you'll get giddy because you
like watching me get excited that's a
different dynamic in that moment all
right it is kind of fun I like watching
uh you know I have a colleague who's
like all into leeches right he
specializes in invertebrates and leeches
among them just to hear them talk about
I don't care about leeches but he does
he's like wow I didn't know anyone could
care that much about a blood sucking
invertebrate but it was just I'm
delighted to watch that all right but so
you saw it things that excite you from
things that could excite someone else
well how do you know you have to
practice that
okay uh strike up conversations watch if
people care about what you say
is there some other conversation that
distracts them from your conversation
with them well go back to the drawing
board on that one
okay and
I also be a good listener watch what
excites other people when they're in
conversations with other people and
that's what I've done so in that way I'm
I'm fully socialized
my parents were social creatures and we
held dinner parties often uh hosting
conversations and I'd watch that uh I'm
a kid so I'm not
for their dinner parties I didn't have a
seat at the table but
um the idea of being able to communicate
and my father's a sociologist that's all
he ever did
uh that I think mattered Within Me
and
you have to be able to read people's
facial you know what we did with my kids
uh it was first evidence that they were
not autistic but also I think it's good
practice
get a when they're old enough
to start thinking about human emotion
Maybe
eight nine to early between years
between 8 and 12.
where they can actively think about what
someone else thinks and feels okay
is the person angry is a person happy is
they sad are they jealous are they
whatever okay
so what I did was
or what you can do is
find a romantic comedy that is well
acted
all right
where so you have stars that really do
it right
and sit down and watch the movie with
the sound off
and have your kids
ask them what do you think
they're thinking now what do you think
she's
feeling what do you think she's saying
what do you think she's going to do next
and you just watch it and the actors are
not only delivering lines they're
feeling
their roles and you might have to wait
if your kid is a little slower that way
maybe they have to be 13 or 14 Middle
School
where your social standing becomes
matters more than in elementary school
where you're not even you don't even
care right so maybe it's a middle school
thing more than an elementary school
thing
in that way you can say you thought she
said well let's check and you go back
and it turns out yes she was jealous in
that moment and so it trains you to read
a facial expression and a good actor
will do this that's what makes them good
actors and you don't rely on the sound
just the visual and it's an exercise in
Reading faces reading people reading
emotions and
so you want to do this
and in the limit you can come in full up
empaths right I think that's a noun yeah
uh an empath
uh that has shaped some people's careers
this is real
we're human we're social creatures so
yeah I fold that in
because I want to reach you
oh and what things do you care about
in my podcast it's called Star Talk
I have a co-host who's a comedian a
professional stand-up comedian
and the anatomy of the podcast is
there's sort of the Trinity there's the
science content there's the humor
and his pop culture
why do I care about pop culture because
you walk into the room already framed in
a scaffold of pop culture
if I know that in advance I don't have
to start from scratch
when I'm teaching you something I'm
going to say oh I have a bit of science
that I can clad onto this part of your
scaffold your pop culture scaffold and
you know something it fits it sticks and
you say whoa I never knew that about
this
there's an American football game that
ended in a tie
and but
we don't end in ties right so there's an
overtime
and you reach a point where it's sudden
death over time sudden death where the
next person that scores wins the game so
this person was was ready to kick for a
it's called a field goal and it's 50
yards out
50 yards oh my gosh okay that's hard so
they kick it
and no one breathes for the three or
four seconds the ball is so the ball
tumbles in the air and there it goes and
everybody just follows it and look it up
and the ball hit the left upright
and careened in
for the win
and I said whoa wait a minute
what's the orientation of the stadium
that's north south
this is a round ball hitting a round
post
and going in
do you realize round things hitting
other round things
fractions of an inch make a difference
so I did a fast calculation and then I
tweeted
the Cincinnati Bengals for the
for the sudden death field goal
was that careened off the upright was
aided
by a one centimeter shift to the right
given to it by the rotation of the Earth
people lost their minds okay people okay
the the Cincinnati Bengals or the local
newspaper said God help them win the
game it's and so everybody so I didn't
have to say what football is who the
Cincinnati Bengals are what a sudden
death goal is what a field goal is or
explain that the goal posts have a left
and a right goal post I didn't have to
introduce any of that that's an example
of the pop culture that someone walks
into the room with and I found a bit of
science that I know they're going to
care about because it touches something
that's pop culture that they already
care about
and I would follow that up with it's a
coriolis force and it's why storms
rotate clockwise counterclockwise in the
northern Hemi I'd follow it up with the
lesson plan but I got your interest yeah
okay yeah I just start out that way
there's such a thing as a coriolis for
no no go away they care
go where they can that and that's what I
do
professionally
if I spoke to Alice and I said your wife
and I said Alice what does Neil struggle
with
what would she say to me struggle with
oh
um personally well I I I don't know
entirely
um but
I know I like to eat more than I like to
exercise
and I used to be very high high highly
tuned athlete so I remember what it's
like to be in complete shape I I
remember I also used to dance so I could
could do a full split I was doing you
know I could I was like totally in shape
and so I have that memory which in a way
is worse than never having been in shape
so she'll say I wouldn't call it
struggling but I would say she would say
that
[Music]
um
I need to carve out more time to
exercise just to stay healthy I think is
so that that's one of them uh another
thing we we talk a lot
that we've been married 34 years
and you'd say what's the secret
you know anytime someone asks you what
the secret is
there being
lazy
because it assumes
just know this one thing and everything
will be better
how much of life actually works that way
when someone said what's your secret to
knowing astrophysics it's like you know
working at it 60 hours a week that's the
secret
somebody asked a chef what's your secret
in this recipe it's because I went to
Chef's school for six years that's the
secret
so I've never asked someone what's your
secret because I that's disrespect for
the actual work that could go into what
it is to gain the expertise or the state
of existence that someone has achieved
um
I think in a marriage it's uh you know
most or half and in divorce within some
number of years so
uh what's what's going on with the
institution and I think
we're not trained
how to communicate
you're living with a person every day of
your life it's really easy to take that
person for granted
it's really easy to
to uh
to enter states of boredom because
you've already talked about so what you
do
you do new things
with each other
as often as you can
iguana trip
explore new hobbies
you go you know you take up a new sport
you play tennis or whatever just do
something new as you would with any
other new person right why does the
other new person look really good
because they're new
okay uh so you could you can always be
new in your marriage if you do new
things
why not travel
travel together then every day is a new
experience you both share so when you
get back home you have something new to
talk about
new to share new to places to grow
and this thing where I want to go on a
dating app where I can find someone
who's just like me
I don't want anyone just like me
I already have me I want someone
different I want someone I can learn
from someone with different interests
that I could grow into
so not that I've ever used a dating app
but if I had a dating app
uh that's I would look for someone who
is just really different and it's odd
because so many of the apps are finding
someone just like you
all right there's now like a Christian
app and a Jewish app and uh this app and
a and a find someone who has this
category it's like wow
why not just have some fun but somebody
who's just different
one of the themes we talk about a lot on
this podcast is mental health and the
conversation around mental health is
really developed over the last 10 years
from a time when we didn't completely oh
my gosh yeah it's a it's complete the
perception of it has completely changed
in terms of being destigmatized but then
our awareness and our understanding of
concept of physical health and mental
health is now more present than ever was
there an event that put your mental
health in focus for yours for you like
really made you cognizant of the fact
that you have mental health and it's
something that you have to
I was going to say Protect but just yeah
keep healthy I guess
that's you know okay I don't have a
simple I have an answer but it's not
simple how much time you got left here
um
there's a friend I told you it's a long
story but you asked it
there was someone my age maybe one year
older
when I was in high school
who died who was the son of a very close
family friend of my parents
we might have played together as very
small children but I didn't know him as
a teenager okay
he died of brain cancer okay very tragic
you're 17 years old and you die of brain
cancer ready to go off to college and
all the rest
they bust in
cool kids
from the school
okay and they unloaded and they filled
this Chapel
and there's a closed casket because it
was it was brain cancer so you know it
was a picture of him on the casket
and I'm watching this
and
the you know the his classmates are like
holding each other as they walk up the
aisle and
there's the organ playing
no it's not a New Orleans song where you
sort of celebrate the life of the person
who just died it was the kind of organ
music where you want to be sad that the
person died
and I'm watching this
and then I start getting emotional
and like a tear
shows up in my eye and I said wait a
minute
I don't know this kid
I don't even remember him
I'd be crying because
the organ is making me cry I'd be crying
because I'm seeing other people who did
know him cry
and I did a fast calculation how many
people are dying in this hour
in the city or in the country or in the
world am I crying for them
who I equally don't know
I rationalized an emotional state out of
this
this pain and misery and I said if I'm
not cheering for everybody else who dies
who I don't know
I should not be tearing for this person
and so I suck the tears back up and just
observed it anthropologically that
there's a funeral going on right in
front of me
that was
an expression
of control over my emotions
that is basically how I lived for the
first
19 years of my life
what was the cost
the cost
no cost why would there be a cost
why should there be a cost
to not having forced emotions by other
to to
no there's
what cost I'm I'm a geek kid okay
and emotions are something that
interfere with rational thought
but this change so what I can say to you
is you're emotional
what's the cost for not being rational
okay I could totally put the question
back on you what's the question you
slammed the door you hung up the phone
back when we had phones to hung up you
slammed it down you cried when you
didn't even know the person okay that's
your cost
so we maybe we're simply different
people I'm not saying they shouldn't
have cried they knew him of course
they're going to cry I didn't
organist
stop making me cry
and so I didn't
okay
so
how did that change
my freshman year college it all changed
it all changed
first semester
I take a class in Art and Design
they play music and they say draw the
music
and it's like
I don't know what you're talking about
feel the music and draw how it makes you
feel I say it's just music I'm listening
to I'm like it's like
two ships passing in the night I don't
know what the hell this person is
talking about I don't know what he means
I don't know you know should I still
stay in this class with is it a waste of
time what's going on here and he says
okay here's what you do draw the energy
in the music
and excuse me I like I'm a physicist
right energy is equals mc squared
there's kinetic energy there's
mechanical energy there's chemical
energy energy is not what you draw out
of music
okay okay
so I said all right I don't know what
he's saying but I'll try something
and then he criticizes it okay so I
don't know what the hell I'm doing why
am I in this class should I drop the
class okay then they roll in the
pumpkins
is they draw the pumpkins okay now I can
I can do this
it's it's a task
there's a pumpkin in front of me I'm
gonna draw it so I draw pumpkins
and it takes me a few tries to get the
hang of it but I'm I'm one of the
world's best pumpkin drawers to this day
because of that we spent weeks drawing
pumpkins and they're also leaning on
each other and they have these sort of
seams in them and the not all of them
have the same size handle the neck that
comes out and some have bruises and
there's like 30 of them up in the front
room so I'm drawing them
I said okay
uh is this is this all we're gonna do
with this okay
after pumpkins became the entire meaning
of my life for two or three weeks
we returned to the studio the pumpkins
are still there and then they said
now
draw the space between the pumpkins
and
I just
snapped
it was like wait a minute you're telling
me that I give object and meaning
objective meaning to these things that
we call pumpkins
and now
these pumpkins are just the boundaries
to something else that I'm giving
meaning to and that's the space between
the pumpkins
it was like
whoa
so
started drawing the space between the
pumpkins
and the pumpkins were now the edges of
things not the object of what I'm
drawing
and my brain
turned inside out
and I started looking around I say
are these lights or is it a shadow that
makes the shape
am I in a space
is the space what's real or is it the
boundary of the space if the boundary
weren't there would I still be in this
space
I still be breathing this air but we
wouldn't call it his face because that
boundary isn't there so the bow so my I
would everything looked different after
them
everything
and from that moment onward
I could talk to artists
with abstract vocabulary
how does this painting feel
what does it do for you
what do you what are your what are your
emotions
it's it it it opened up a box
an emotional state that was previously
non-communicative
with the rest of my mind it was kept
there I could act it's not that I didn't
know how to cry
it's just that the crying had nothing to
do with anything else that was
objectively real
so what they did it it it found the
place where it pried had opened and
there was spillage there was cross
spillage
so I can tell you this now
there's no way this sentence could have
come out of my head
on my iPhone I have skin it's not a
casing it's just what's called a skin
and it is a section of Van Gogh's starry
night
the actual name of the painting is the
starry night okay
it's got these swirly beautiful colors
and all right
it's my favorite painting
why
because
it's certainly not what he saw
the sky has never looked this way
but it's definitely what he felt
and for me
an artist's task
their Duty in this world not to
prescribe about this but for me their
duty is to show me the world
as I do not see it
take me someplace give me a perspective
that will broaden my interpretation of
reality
that is a thought an idea a sentence
that could have never come out of my
mouth
until that moment where I drew the space
between the pumpkins
and that access to abstract thinking to
now in the early days I'd watch a
Broadway musical and two people walk up
to each other speaking uh oh a song is
about to happen and then they sing about
their love for each other I say why
don't you just cut the song just say you
love each other move on to the next
scene
that's how I felt as a child
after college after that course
I see the two people walk up to each
other and they're speaking their
emotions and I'm saying you know
when you sing your emotions it reaches a
deeper part not only within yourself
but within the listeners
because there's more
of your emotion expressed
when you sing
and so now I long
for the song in a Broadway musical
the simplicity
of expressed emotion
so I don't want to quite say I'm the
opposite of what I was when I suck back
the tears in that funeral
but I'm going to say that
dare I suggest a well-developed
access
to both your emotions and your rational
self
with some control over the two you don't
want rampant contamination but just be
able to close the door every now and
then between the two and then open it I
think conservice greatly as a
civilization
if I were to offer
perspective and advice
there are times where you need your
rational self otherwise you will not
make a decision that's in the best
interest of your health your wealth or
your security
but don't let that hide what emotions
you might have
because the world's greatest art as far
as I can tell issues fourth
from rampant emotion that we're capable
of as human beings
Neil thank you we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest asks a question for the next guest
without knowing who they're going to ask
it for and they write it in this book
and I don't get to see it till open it
is fun once you get to see it now I get
to see it now okay Jack Jack always
looks but I never look
when was the last time you cried and why
uh
I cry often
now that the door to my emotions has
been found in
Pride open so I cry often I cry at very
simple things I cry at uh
simple emotional moments in
in in a play
resident of New York city so we consume
as many londoners surely you consume the
theater scene
um I'll cry even in a moment in a
musical my musical is supposed to make
you happy but there might be a tender
moment I tear up if I see
acts of
of
um
sensitivity and kindness
in a situation where you would not
expect it
okay
if you see a war-torn scene and a
soldier
picks up a doll and hands it to a child
does it
a soldier who's
brandishing a weapon for killing people
and they take a moment
to do that
I'll tear up I'm tearing up now just
thinking of such a scene
when that happens
so
I tear up in
unexpected acts of kindness
because it's
hope for the world
I'll tear up in a movie
uh usually in a theater because it's a
big immersive experience less so at home
on a TV even the same movie I might feel
a little more in a theater immersiveness
matters because it's
it's coming at you for more in more ways
with greater strength the sound is
greater the visual effects are greater
uh you're there as a participant in the
film so
um so I I probably will tear up once or
twice a week
for those reasons and more but those are
the more common sort of reasons that
arise
Neil thank you thank you for the
inspiration over the last decade thank
you for
um being the Starry Messenger in my life
which is the name of your new book
because you were it's funny I was
thinking about it as as we started this
conversation that that was actually the
moment that I became obsessed with the
universe when I first watched you
present Cosmos all those years ago
um and this book is just a continuation
of that but it's a very current book in
the sense that it speaks to some of the
profound issues that are happening in
the world the inside cover I think
presents a really great explanation of
that in a time when our political and
cultural views feel more polarized than
ever Tyson provides a much needed
antidote to so much of what divides us
while making a passionate case for the
twin Chariots of Enlightenment a cosmic
perspective
and the rationality of science
and that's exactly what this book is
it's a necessary antidote to the modern
times we're living in well thank you for
your support of that I will say that
Starry Messenger comes from Galileo
where he first perfects the telescope
after only just having heard that a
telescope was invented in the
Netherlands he said oh my gosh that's
let me make my own version of it he
makes the best version that exists in
the world observes the night sky
notices that Venus goes through phases
which can only happen if Venus is going
around the Sun and not around Earth uh
it could he notices that the sun has
spots the moon has craters the Jupiter
has moons that orbit it he didn't call
in moons they're called Jupiter's stars
because why would you think they were
moons who knows and he reports this with
the first evidence that Earth is not the
center of all emotion
and he called it siderius nuncius
Starry Messenger
the Star Messenger wasn't him the story
messenger was these messages themselves
from the sky
that are conflicting with prevailing
belief systems about humans and about
Earth
and he got into big trouble with the
church
so what I as an astrophysicist I found
all the starry messages I could
and applied them
to our plight here on Earth and that's
the summary of what's going on in that
book death is a topic you mentioned in
this book yes life and death life and
death I'm more compelled by death as
should we all be
yeah I I was a Christian growing up
until the age of about 18 and then when
I discovered atheism or agnosticism or
whatever they want to call it my
perspective of death change and I
actually became really comfortable with
death the prospect of death where do you
think and where are you at in
your perspective and thoughts on death
for myself or just in general in general
and yourself probably quite Inseparable
I imagine I don't know death
uh it death comes up as a
as a topic of conversation
commonly when we talk about
prolonging life
and now that we're into the genome and
into human physiology might there be a
day where you can live forever
okay and there's something called The
Generation that will have escape
velocity do you know what that is
okay I'll tell you what it is so in the
last 50 years
we've increased life expectancy 20 years
in the last 10 years we've increased
life expectancy by five years
so there will be a time where in the
last year we increase life expectancy by
a year
at that moment
Homo sapiens have achieved escape
velocity from death
okay that generation will never die
unless you're hit by a bus okay
so that brings you the question
if you could live forever
would you
and
my reply to that and I don't want to
answer for other people so this is my I
want to be very clear that yes I have my
opinions but I don't care if you share
my opinions should have your own
opinions okay my Outlook on this is
well let's take for example a bouquet of
flowers
if you buy a bouquet of flowers and hand
them to your loved one and the bouquet
the flowers are made of plastic
how would your loved one reply to that
they they probably think you don't love
them
but you say but darling
they'll last forever okay
no that's not the variable here that's
not what matters
the fact that flowers die
is the very reason why they have meaning
as a gift
your hand at flowers They're going to be
dead in seven days that means you know
you better pay attention to them you're
going to smell them you're going to take
care of them you're going to make sure
you change the water and trim the stems
and you're gonna put it in a central
place so that not only you see them but
so does everybody else
you're going to celebrate those flowers
while they are alive
because the day is going to come very
quickly
where they're going to die
and in their senescence you're gonna
nurse them through
as the neck gets a little weak on the
stem you might try to prop them up
until
they're gone
it is the fact that they're going to die
that gives them meaning as a gift
and dare I say that my knowledge that
I'm going to die
gives not only meaning
to my being alive
it gives urgency to it
on my deathbed I do not want to regret
having the interest and ability to have
solved the problem that I did not solve
uh to have an experience that I could
have had but then I did not
knowing I'm going to die means
I'm gonna wake up in the morning
and
I'm going to be all about action
action
I was I will tell people I love them if
I love them I will accomplish things I
will learn this thing I wanted to learn
I will do all I can
because you know what I wanted my
tombstone
it's a quote
from a famous American educator of two
centuries ago his name is Horace Mann
who's also a university president I
think it was he gave a commencement
speech one of his last
and he says to the graduates I beseech
you love that word nobody uses that word
anymore beseeche
Shakespeare loved it
I beseech you to treasure up in your
hearts
these my parting words
be ashamed to die
until you have scored some victory for
Humanity
I want that on my tombstone
I don't want any other Monument
but that
on my tombstone
if everyone lived to that goal
how different the world would be how
enriched it would be
with people's energy
to improve the lot not only of others as
individuals but of
your neighborhood your Society
civilization itself
so that's what I think of
when I think of death
by the way
in there I referenced
dogs
there's a dog over there for anyone
there's a dog over there called Leica in
the corner of this room like where I
heard that name like uh
65 years ago
like a orbits Earth
if I Stoke to Opeth the first animal
to orbit Earth
then there's some guinea pigs and then
there are some chimps
and then Yuri Gagarin orbits the earth
the first human I think he was the
seventh mammal to orbit the earth I had
to check my notes on this but it was if
you add up mammals humans were very late
in the in the space achievement scale
so
when you come home for having been away
if you own a dog you will know exactly
what I'm describing by the way this does
not happen with cats
so with a dog
the dog is happy to see you
not just happy hey glad you're home it's
they jump up and down and they want to
lick your face and they want to jump
into your lap if it's a lap dog and if
it's a if it's an Irish Wolfhound
they'll want to knock you over and lick
you in the face
they're excited
by you
first I would ask did you do anything
that day that deserved that praise all
right so one famous quote is be the
person that your dog thinks you are
okay that's a high bar let me say
but there's the and by the way if you go
out to just check the mail
and come back the dog is happy to see
you
so now wait a minute
why
uh let me just make up a reason okay
I'm just pulling this out of my ass you
ready
okay
uh dogs don't live as long as we do
the famous dog year calculation there's
some nuances to it but the blunt
calculation is one dog year is seven
human years okay
so when a dog is 10 they're like 70.
all right when a dog is 12 they're 84.
they're getting ready to die okay dogs
die between age basically 12 and 16.
okay all right
wait a minute if it's a factor of seven
difference
it means
we live an entire week of Our Lives
for every single day a dog lives
so maybe the dog knows
it won't live as long as we will maybe
it knows
it's got a truncated life expectancy
relative to humans maybe it knows it's
got to make Every Day Count
we could languish away five days out of
the week you still have the other two
days to watch football with your friends
the dog doesn't have that luxury
so I'm making this up I'm going to
declare
that dogs know that every day of their
lives matter
and therefore they're going to make it
count and they're going to be happy
every day
you ever wake up to a dog that's
depressed never
uh no
you know I'll walk myself today don't
worry about it I'll feed myself I don't
want to eat up no they've been sick
all right that's how you know they're
sick they're not licking you in the face
that's a sad day for the dog
but then they pop back dogs don't stay
sick for long
because they live seven times faster
than we do
have you ever taken a dog to the vet
and they perform surgery
on the dog
okay
you know where I'm going here they
perform surgery the next day the dog is
out running around in the park
I've seen dog with the leg amputated
amputated leg
and the next day they're a little slower
but they're kind of walking around and
they still want to lick you in the face
and as good as new after three days if
we had one of our legs amputated oh my
gosh I'm still in the hospital a month
later
dogs live in the fast lane
and maybe they know it
and so I want to think to myself
no I'm not licking people in the face
but I want to experience the joy and the
urgency the dogs do
simply by being alive
Neil thank you thank you for the
generosity of your time thank you for
all the inspiration thank you for uh
schooling me in the most
um
unintentional way on how to be a
wonderful engaging communicator and how
to make very complex subject matter fun
and accessible for everybody well thank
you can I end with the beginning quote
of the book please may I
at the beginning of the book I wanted to
set the mood
because Earth from space is very
different than Earth from Earth's
surface
oh
dedicated to the memory of Cyril
deGrasse Tyson and all others who want
to see the world as it could be rather
than as it is
my father okay so here's the quote
Apollo astronaut
Edgar Mitchell
Apollo 14.
he went to the moon and saw Earth
because that's kind of what happened we
went to the moon to discover the moon to
explore the moon and we look back over
our shoulders and we kind of discovered
Earth for the first time
the birth of the modern
conservation and environmental movement
began while we were walking on the moon
because there was Earth adrift alone
in the darkness of space
with no hint that help would come from
elsewhere
to save us from ourselves it's a that
very line is in Carl Sagan penned in his
book a pale blue dot so here's Edgar
Mitchell
you develop an instant Global
Consciousness a people orientation an
intense dissatisfaction with the state
of the world and a compulsion to do
something about it
from out there on the moon International
politics looks so petty you want to grab
a politician by the Scruff of the neck
and drag him a quarter million miles out
and say look at that you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
we're done
from one of our sponsors I've got a tip
for all of you that will make your
virtual meeting experiences I think 10
times better as some of you may know by
now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events quick
one as you might know crafted are one of
the sponsors of this podcast and crafted
are a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry I think
I've worn this piece for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 Quid I'm not the
type of person that has Rolexes or
jewelry that cost tens of thousands of
pounds I want pieces that are reliable
that look beautiful and that holds
meaning and significance for me and
that's exactly why I've worn crafted for
so long and when we have the
conversation about them sponsoring this
podcast I was so unbelievably Keen for
them to do so check it out if you're a
guy crafted london.com and yeah if you
get any pieces of crafted tag man let me
know what you think
foreign
[Music]